as a small tangent let me ask you
something about
um parlor but it's less about parlor
more about aws
so aws removed parlor from his platform
you know for whatever reasons doesn't
really matter but the fact that
aws would do this was really
really bothered me personally because um
i saw aws as the computing
infrastructure
and i always thought that part could not
put a finger on its scale
and i don't know what your thoughts are
like were you bothered by
uh parlor being removed from aws and how
does that
affect how you think about the computing
infrastructure on which
librex is based i was bothered not so
much by
parlor specifically being taken out of
aws but more
the fact that something that's like a
highway
something that people rely on that
people build on top of
that people assume is going to be
somewhat positioned agnostic
um like a road that people drive on is
is becoming ideologically sort of
discriminatory
i just and of course mind you amazon can
do what it wants it's a private company
and i support the rights of private
companies i just on an
ethical and sort of a deep moral level i
wonder like at what point
should a company sort of be agnostic in
that in that regard
and let developers build on top of their
infrastructure
and where where does that responsibility
hold
yes it makes you uh hope that there's
going to be
from a capitalistic sense competitors to
aws would say like we're not going to
put our finger on the scale
i mean on the highway is a good sort of
example
it's like if a privately owned highway
exactly
said uh you know we're no longer going
to allow
we're only going to allow electric
vehicles
and a bunch of people in this world
would be like yes because
electric is good for the environment and
uh
you know yes but then
you have to consider the like the
slippery slope nature of it
but also like the the negative impact on
the lives of many others
and what that means for innovation and
for like uh
competition again in a capitalistic
sense so there's some nature
there's some level to this hierarchy of
our existence
that we should not allow to manipulate
what's built on top of it it should be
truly infrastructure
and it feels like compute is uh storage
and compute
is the that layer like it shouldn't be
messed with
i haven't seen anybody really complain
about it like in terms of government and
i'm not even sure government is the
right mechanism through policy and
regulation to step
in because again they do a messy job of
fixing things
but i do hope there's competitors to aws
to make
aws and step up because i do think you
know i'm a fan of aws
except this service it's a good service
until this
until yeah until they rip out the the
rug
and the point is it's not that
necessarily their decision
was a bad one with parlor in particular
it's that like the the slippery slope
nature of it but also
the it takes the good actors that are
creating amazing products
and makes them more fearful and when
you're more fearful it's the same reason
that anonymity is a tool
that you don't create the best thing you
could possibly create when you're
fearful you don't
create
you